et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec khaled mot pas un
correspondant rt aux etats unis c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soit
bonsoir quel est mon pain merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on le
voit en ce débat le racisme les
violences policières
cela devient un enjeu notamment dans la
campagne présidentielle avec clairement
deux visions qui s'affrontent entre les
républicains et les démocrates
mbc diaboliser les taxes de tourisme et
les démocrates contraire les ça ne
marche avec eux les soutiennent
explosion des soutiens pour la
revendication n'est certains
républicains plus centriste soutiennent
également ces manifestants par exemple
métro moi qui étais rival pour barack
obama lors de l'élection de 2014 de 2012
donc il ya vraiment un fossé entre cela
et le reste de des institutions
politiques
alors on le voit aussi un job hayden qui
prend la balle au bond si j'ose dire
l'heure de la justice raciale a sonné
alors qu'il n'a pas toujours été très
clair sur ces questions raciales un job
haydn par le passé effectivement joe
biden a déjà poussé vers ce qu'il ya où
il était pour l'incarcération de masse
dans les années 1990 il travaillait avec
quelqu'un qui l'a résultats pour les le
conseil démocratique sld des dirigeants
qui a ramené les démocrates verts une
mouvance conservatrice et demandé plus
de loi et d'ordre critiquant les
républicains en disant qu'il n'était pas
assez sévères
en matière de condamnations en matière
de peine
mon parti démocrate à l'époque joe biden
connaissait son essor et et c'est encore
le parti des officiers de police de
l'incarcération de masse est le parti
qui jouant sur la peur des afro
américains par exemple en parler de
super prédateur le parti jouer sur
l'idée que le jeune afro-américain
représenter un danger est donc
effectivement il a un lourd passif on
essaye de le faire oublier il a il a
émis des campagnes publicitaires le
plaçant au centre des mouvements pour
plus de liberté de droits civiques
mais ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai alors
on voit que le temps des réformes est
venu avec cette étape
voilà crucial ces tensions après
laffaire giorgio fleuve il a commencé
par le démantèlement de la la police à
minneapolis faut-il s'attendre à
d'autres gros changements à l'échelle
nationale aux états unis concernant la
police de composition différentes qu'il
est difficile de suivre et les mandats
couper les vivres à la police maintenant
de réduire les budgets des départements
de police locaux ont été démantelés à
seattle des manifestants et créer une
zone autonome autant dans un
commissariat de police
il y a beaucoup de propositions très
différentes certains demandent de plus
de pouvoir fédéral par rapport à la
police locale qui a beaucoup d'idées
différentes et le parti démocrate et la
plupart des gens dans les institutions
politiques semblent justifier le donald
trump pense que ses idées sont
terroristes et demande lui fait pression
forte et au sein de l'armée il ya des
gens qui dénoncent et condamnent les
idées de balades trompe beaucoup de
personnes pensent que l'oreille du
président dans une telle période serait
de calmer la situation de désamorcer les
choses mettons à 30 pour ces raisons
pour des raisons politiques lui sont
propres afin d'assembler héroïque pour
elle sa base électorale verse de l'huile
sur le feu parce que j'ai pour lui cela
représente un avantage politique qui
reste beaucoup le critique car cela dit
ce qu'ils n'essayent pas de calmer la
situation
tu ne fais que manipuler la crise afin
de servir ses propres intérêts afin de
se faire bien paraître auprès de sa base
électorale
est-ce que selon vous qui êtes un
observateur évidemment de cette vie
politique américaine est ce que c'est
une bonne stratégie qu'ils adoptent
donald trump
quand on voit l'opinion des américains
est ce que justement ça va le servir
dans sa campagne ou non je pense qu'il y
a de bonnes chances que cette stratégie
soit très très efficace à cause du
système électoral américain certains
états ont bien plus de points que
d'autres cas
s'agit pas d'une élection directe et la
victoire en 2016 était largement due au
fait que des personnes âgées dans
certains états tels que l'appétit venant
par exemple ont voté pour donald trump
alors qu'auparavant ils voter qu est que
donald trump et c'est vraiment un héros
qui pouvait défendre une amérique en
train de disparaître qui paraîtront et
ces personnes pourraient une fois de
plus pesé et faire basculer les versions
communauté n'aime pas du tout les
manifestations et pense qu'on n'a pas
assez de recettes pour la police à pul
solaire pourrait jouer en faveur de
trump à l'est la communauté
afro-américaine la parité pour hillary
clinton en 2016 ils sont restés chez eux
lorsque c'était hillary clinton qui
s'étendit berthet et même lors des
dernières élections
beaucoup de personnes se sont rendues
dans les bureaux de vote pour voter
contre donald trump donc il est
difficile de savoir comment cela va se
passer mais en tout cas effectivement
c'est l avantage de toni trucks de
critiquer le manifestant en tout cas si
on vous comprend bien pour la communauté
afro américaine
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas vraiment de
candidat idéal à cette présidentielle
merci à tous de couloir apprécié que
bynum il a beaucoup de soutien lors des
primaires et beaucoup de personnes se
demandaient qui est chaude allen va-t-il
choisir en tant que vice président mais
si l'on étudie le passé de jeu dans
lequel il y avait au cours des faux pas
en matière de racisme de relations
interraciales qui révèle peut-être des
préjudices
donc ce n'est pas effectivement le
candidat idéal pour les manifestants et
les militants qui manifestent
actuellement mais en tout cas à dubaï
deuil
beaucoup plus raisonnables et semble
plus raisonnable pour les languedociens
alors que donald trump les qualifie de
terroristes et souhaite qu'on refoule
toutes ces personnes merci beaucoup
qu'elle a vraiment pas un correspondant
rt aux etats-unis nous avoir apporté
votre analyse ce soit